all right we're here with John Hargrove
John great job out there tonight how was
it
thank you it was uh actually it was it
was more comfortable than I thought I
actually appreciated his questions and
it was it was easier to get involved in
what he was asking me and not think
about the fact that I was live on HBO
with Bill Maher it was good at putting
people at ease and you were in this
documentary blackfish
which is coming out in theaters now and
I just want to ask why blackfish well
you know Native American Indians they
called them blackfish
let's work kind of the you know the name
they had you figured out the whole
mammal yeah I doubt this well they I
doubt there's still people that I talk
to on a daily basis still haven't
connected that they're mammals I get
asked a lot if they're sharks if they're
fish what is the coolest thing that
you've witnessed the way I'll do the
most profound moment of not only my
killer whale training career but really
my life is watching these whales the
good especially the good mothers like
Takara and kosaka the leaks that they
would go to and the devotion that they
had and teaching their calf everything
and protecting this calf and just
because it's such a lengthy process you
know a great example for that is when
Takara gave birth to Sakaki because the
calf still has not developed its motor
skills yet and it's a coordination and
there's a risk of the calf running into
the bottom of the poor hitting the glass
or even swimming by the gate where the
other whales are and what you know not
knowing exactly how those other whales
could react to the calf to car did not
stop swimming for almost three months so
no no resting no sleeping we would have
to feed her as she was making the loop
around the pool on the fly we would be
reaching out to the side and through an
aid station and the triathlon they just
like yeah half exactly so she would not
stop at all because the calf's motor
skills you know had not developed yet so
when you see an animal willing to go
to that extreme of devotion and when she
stopped swimming into that third month
she was just exhausted and the movie
they show to look I'm getting captured
right and it's it's really dramatic and
you can tell how terrible it is and
traumatizing for the animal is it any
better
raising them in captivity and doing this
insemination program I don't think so
beginning in 2000 we started we
perfected the artificial insemination
process how invasive is that it's very
invasive you know we you know it's not
there's no mood lighting no no no and
they you know you know more more
horrific because you can really
condition the the obviously the the
procedure itself is invasive but the
fact that these whales carry you know
their gestation is nearly 18 months and
then after they give birth
they'll nurse their young for up to two
years teaching this calf everything and
protecting this gaff and then most of
these mothers are stripped away from
their calves so after carrying it for 18
months nursing it for up to two years
teaching this calf everything and then
just to have it stripped away and then
to be artificially inseminated right
away again so we will actually monitor
their cycles and they won't cycle again
for about a year and a half after they
give birth and as soon as they start to
cycle again we will re artificially
inseminate them so they're really
treating these whales at this point like
a baby machine I know you're doing all
this out of great love for these animals
and I wish you the best of luck with the
film and with accomplishing your your
mission do they say these guys thank you
for helping us out and helping us put
this out there I really appreciate it
John take care thank you